hi there Steve Kaufman here there seems
to be a fair interest in this idea of
how I go about learning different
languages and so I'm going to deal with
the requests as they come forward and so
the first request was for German how did
I go about learning German okay first of
all you have to understand that my
parents were born in the
austro-hungarian Empire they were born
in a town called Prost off which is in
Moravia which was then a part of the
austro-hungarian Empire which today is a
part of the Czech Republic and the
austro-hungarian Empire was largely
german-speaking and much of maybe a
third or somewhat less than a third of
the population of what then became
Czechoslovakia was german-speaking my
parents spoke German at home although
they went to school in Czech so they
were bilingual in German and Czech and
they spoke other languages as well
they left Czechs like in 1939 before
Hitler came in and moved to Sweden which
is where I was born and the whole family
moved to Canada when I was five that's
back in 1951 as soon as we arrived in
Canada my parents said we are now in
Canada you will speak English and so we
always spoke English at home which I
appreciate because I'm not a fan of
parents who forced their kids to learn
the ancestral language you know
certainly I learned a lot of languages
before I learned German or Czech
I'm working my Czech now but we heard
German at home and we didn't like it my
brother and I because like many
immigrants my parents spent a good part
of their time criticizing Canada and
Canadians and there's no culture and
they're lazy and no education and you
know in the old country everything was
better and so all her friends tended to
be of a similar background and so we
resented them and whenever my parents
would tell me that you know look at
so-and-so son or daughter or so on so
you know she plays the violin or the
piano and and all I wanted to do was
play hockey and so they were a model of
what to be and so I resented everything
to do with German or Czech or Europe
however this all changed when I was 19
after two years at McGill University and
very much feeling that I was wasting my
time at the University and I didn't know
what I wanted to do and and I was
actually working on construction on a
construction site sort of like a gofer
for carpenters on this big construction
site and all of a sudden they didn't
need me anymore so I was let go
I remember it was like a two-hour
commute by bus they get this
construction cellulous it was but anyway
it was fine I guess I made some money
two dollars and fifty cents an hour I
remember I thought that was a lot of
money back in whenever it was 1963 so I
went down to the Port of Montreal and
for three days I asked I went to ships
that were in port and in those days they
were primarily from Europe and I asked
to go go on board to speak to the
captain and to ask if I could work my
way across to Europe I had decided to
hitchhike across to Europe and then
hitchhike around in Europe and possibly
stay there and go to University in
Europe the third day I was lucky there
was a German ship a small sort of [ __ ]
steamer I believe it was five thousand
tons was very small ship and the captain
said yes we lost a sailor in Quebec City
you can come and work with us and we'll
take you across to London so I was on a
German ship the crew was half German
half Spanish the Germans were drunk
every night the Spanish were certainly
more hard-working than the Germans and I
had my German book with me and I can
remember trying to you know all that
dared em DDoS and trying to figure out
German grammar and I kind of I guess I
was able to say a few things the German
spoke English the Spanish didn't um at
least some of the Germans then so then I
hitchhiked around in Europe and France
and many other places and then ended up
in Vienna where my father had arranged
for me to work again on a construction
site for two weeks as part of my tour
where I made a little bit of money lived
in an abandoned building with a bunch of
Turkish guest workers and so I guess I
spoke a little bit of German there and
than a hitchhike in German so I was
always kind of stumbling but never could
really speak the language then in 1987 I
was I was working for a major Canadian
corporation forest products company
called Macmillan Bloedel I was hired
away by another company called Canadian
forest products I had a month off
between jobs I said now I'm going to
learn German so I went to secondhand
bookstores in Vancouver and I'm to some
extent new bookstores but there's not
there wasn't that much stuff in German
but I found basically what I wanted to
do was read and listen so you know the
first book I got all these books here
but I'll show you some of the ones this
was one of the earliest books I found in
bundle diyaa and so it's all full of
like somebody had you know full of stuff
and let's see if I can show this better
and somebody else had marked it up and
it had all kinds of glossary and stuff
so I just read through this and then
there was a thing called a laser here
and it was much the same more text just
plain reading and I read and I would
just sit at my home for hours and hours
and hours and read German there was
another one where was it anyway there is
lots of them where Duke Duke Deutschland
mentioning machine and whatever I could
find
ah you know I'll tell again neue
literate or the bending elytra to this
was kind of getting more advanced
actually taming yes Liz envía but there
was one other die I thought I grabbed
them but they I got lots so I just read
and listened and one of I was I looked
for any kind of CD system that I could
find the best one that I found was one
that was basically radio programs
interviews with all kinds of people I
remember there was one who was a
locomotive engineer in Cologne who once
had the Queen of England on his
train there was a farmer from Bavaria
and it was just natural conversation and
that was actually influential because
when we started the linguist which is
the predecessor to link we I began by
going out and interviewing all kinds of
people in different walks of life
because our target at that point was the
sort of skilled immigrant who comes in
theoretically speaking English but in
fact can't communicate very well and I
felt there is nothing better than
genuine conversations with people just
listen and listen and listen so with my
German so I did all this reading
building up my vocabulary just out of
interest I decided then I'm gonna do it
and this is something about language
learning you've got to decide you're
gonna do it and then you do it in a very
concentrated fashion so I did that and
it turns out that I didn't last long at
the new company Canadian Forest Products
because I had a big disagreement with my
new boss and so I decided to bail on
that company within three months
otherwise you know once you get going
and you make contact with their customer
base and everything else I said I'm not
happy here I made a bad decision or
whatever but I'm out of here
so then I set up my own company in 1987
now it just so happens that in my new
company which was exporting lumber we
ended up with business in Germany so I
ended up having an agent in Germany and
in the early 90s I traveled to Germany
with him and he would speak with in
German as we drove around or as is often
the case in Germany as we sat in traffic
not moving at all and so I worked on it
and I just I just would listen and read
and listen and read and when I had an
opportunity to speak I would speak and I
mean I can easily go back to those
grammar cables but I can't absorb them
because the DET en or es or ER e em
shows up in the genitive and the net
neuter and the fact I just can't
remember them so I just speak however it
comes that's the way I speak and that's
basically the nature of my German what
else can I say about German so in the
90s it's when I had most of my exposure
to Germany to German rather but I was
there for two weeks a couple of years
ago
I got very interested in the 30 Years
War I mean I got lots of I could go and
grab them I got lots of audiobooks in
German and in particular is one audio
book on the 30 Years War was fascinating
because I had a Eurail pass for Germany
and I was in Augsburg and in Munich and
then I was in Prague and so these are
all places that were very much involved
with the 30 Years War and then I took a
train and eventually I was up in around
Hamburg and and Cologne and so forth and
so on but whenever I go to Germany I
enjoy it I tried to use it as much as
possible I I find like every language I
find it if fascinating I only wish I had
more time to spend on German but but
basically I am sure that hearing German
as a child helped me but you have still
got to make the effort and to me before
I start speaking I need words so
therefore my first impulse always is to
read and to read a lot so I was reading
that month that I took off in 1987 I was
reading three four or five hours a day
reading and listening reading and
listening and that was essentially my
experience when I learned Chinese when I
learned Japanese reading and listening
and you don't have to be in the country
to do that now yeah there you have it
that's my German situation and I got to
run an hour I'd do the other ones there
were some people asking me about Swedish
and French and Spanish so we'll
eventually get to those anyway there you
are thanks for listening bye for now